consider the following Alice and Bob
have figured out how to transmit
messages between their treehouses at
first they use flames at night and
shudders during the day then they used a
wire which they plucked in different
ways eventually they electrified this
wire to send electrical pulses and were
now at work on an experimental wireless
method the problem is in order to pay
for their equipment they needed money so
they decided to offer their service for
a fee to others and on the first day
Alice had three new customers who wanted
to transmit messages to their friends
over at Bob's treehouse the first
customer wanted to send a list of 10
coin flips the second customer wanted to
send a six letter word and the third
customer wanted to send a poker hand the
question now is how much did she charge
well the price of a message should
depend on how long it takes Alice to
transmit it but how could she measure
the length of different types of
messages using a common unit to find out
let's play a game
imagine you were Bob now and you know
Alice wants to send you these messages
but all you can do is get the answer to
yes-or-no questions you've arranged
Alice will answer by sending a sequence
of zeros or ones using some method of
variation recall that all their methods
of transmission involve the exchange of
differences so a 1 could be represented
by an open flame or an open shutter or
an electrical pulse no matter how they
are manifested we can simply call them
binary digits because a binary digit can
have only one of two values 0
one so let's say zero represents an O
and one represents a yes your challenge
now is to always ask the minimum number
of questions in order to determine the
exact message first let's consider the
coin flips for each symbol the sender
Alice can be thought of as selecting one
of two different symbols heads or tails
now how many questions do you need to
ask to determine which she selected one
question such as is it heads will
suffice for 10 flips what is a minimum
number of questions both 10 flips x one
question per flip equals 10 questions or
10 binary digits to transmit this
message next let's consider the letters
for each symbol the sender Alice can be
thought of as selecting one of 26
different symbols let's start with the
simplest message which is one letter how
many questions are needed is it a is it
B is it C is it D and so on but that is
not the minimum number of questions
the best you could do is ask questions
which eliminate half of the
possibilities for example the middle of
the alphabet is between m and n so we
could first ask is it less than n if we
receive a 1 yes we cut out half of the
possibilities which leaves 13 left and
since we can't split a letter in half we
divide the possible symbols in two sets
of 6 and 7 and ask is it less than G we
receive a 1 which is yes and now we are
left with 6 possible letters and we can
split them in half and ask is it less
than D we receive a 0 which is no
leaving us with 3 possible letters and
now we can pick a side and ask is it d
we receive a 0 which is no and finally
we are left with two possibilities we
ask is it e we receive a no and after
five questions we have correctly
identified the symbol F realize that we
will never need to ask more than 5
questions so the number of questions
will be at least 4 and at most 5 and in
general two to the power of number of
questions equals the number of possible
messages which we previously defined as
the message space so how can we
calculate the exact average or expected
number of questions given a message
space of 26 we ask the reverse question
two to the power of something equals 26
and to answer these types of questions
we naturally use a logarithmic function
base two because log base two of 26 is
the exponent two needs to be raised to
to give us 26 which is approximately
four point seven so on average
approximately four point seven questions
will be needed per letter at
and since she wants to transmit a word
with six letters
Bob can expect to ask at minimum twenty
eight point two questions which means
Alice will need to send at most twenty
nine binary digits finally let's apply
this formula to a new message the poker
hand well for each symbol the sender
Alice can be thought of as selecting one
of 52 different symbols and in this case
a number of questions is the same as the
number of times we need to split the
deck and ask Alice which pilot is in
until we are left with one card which we
will find is usually six splits or
questions and sometimes five but we can
save time and just use our equation log
base two of 52 is approximately five
point seven since two to the power of
five point seven is approximately 52 so
the minimum number of questions on
average is five point seven per card a
poker hand contains five cards so to
transmit a poker hand requires
twenty-eight point five questions on
average we are done we now have our unit
it's based on the minimum number of
questions to define the message or the
height of the decision tree and since
Alice transmits this information as
binary digits we can shorten this and
call our unit the bit instead of binary
digit so we have ten coin flips requires
ten bits the six letter word requires
twenty eight point two bits and the
poker hand requires twenty eight point
five bits Alice then decides to charge
one penny per bit and begins collecting
her fees now this idea emerged in the
1920s it was one of the more abstract
problems that communication engineers
were thin
about Ralph Hartley was a prolific
electronics researcher who built on the
ideas of Harry Nyquist both of whom
worked at Bell Labs after World War one
and in 1928 Hartley published an
important paper titled the transmission
of information and in it he defines the
word information using the symbol H as H
equals n times the logarithm of s where
each is our information n is the number
of symbols whether they're notes letters
numbers etc and s is the number of
different symbols available at each
selection and this can also be written
as h equals the logarithm of s to the
power of n and Hartley writes what we
have done then is to take as our
practical measure of information the
logarithm of the number of possible
symbols sequences so information is the
logarithm of the message space however
realize that throughout this lesson we
have been assuming that the symbol
selection is random convenient
simplification however we know that in
reality most communication such as
speech isn't always random it's a subtle
mix of predictability and surprise you
do not roll dice when we write letters
and it is this predictability which can
result in significant savings in the
length of transmission because when we
can predict things in advance we
shouldn't need to ask as many yes-or-no
questions to define it but how could we
formally model this subtle difference
this question brings us to the key
insight in our story can you think of
what it might be
you